Kohl's
is selling not just Pride gear which we
now expect of
a great number I'm not going to say
almost every company there was still
some reasonable companies that reject
the modern rainbow but but many
companies perhaps even most companies no
it's not just that they're selling Pride
gear they're selling Pride baby onesies
to celebrate pride month Kohl's is
selling the baby Sonoma Community Pride
bodysuit set that's only 9.99 what a
deal the description reads celebrate the
joy that comes from living authentically
and unapologetically during pride month
and all year long with this baby Sonoma
Community Pride bodysuit set that onesie
is sold for babies as young as three
months old
The Collection features adults and
children marching and carrying an LGBT
flag and sitting all together with all
sorts of rainbow sorts of gear on
one of the images of this is two men who
somehow have found themselves in
in custody of three children and this is
to celebrate pride month which which
shows you why
these shops why
the whole culture has to push the pride
stuff onto kids
I know that there are the squishes who
say the pride stuff is just for the
adults and we just shouldn't have it for
kids fine for the adults we shouldn't
have it for the children transgenderism
fine for adults we shouldn't have it for
children but that doesn't work because
we live in society so the reason that
Target or whatever Kohl's here is going
to be selling little pride
three-month-old onesies is not because
the the three-month-old is going to
identify as LGBT soon enough I'm sure
people are going to claim that that
happens but the reason is because
we've now redefined marriage to say that
two men or two women are the same as a
man and a woman in marriage that that's
all just marriage we've redefined
having children
to say that two men can have a child
together whether through scientific
experiments in a test tube or through
adoption
same goes for two women same soon we'll
go for thruppels and all the rest of it
so the onesies like all baby onesies are
not for the three-month-old the onesies
are for the parents and if we're going
to affirm this radical redefinition of
human society then we're gonna have to
do it at every level
this this is the same argument for
transgenderism if we're going to say
that a man can secretly be a woman then
that has to be true for every level it
doesn't just magically happen when
someone turns 18.
the human nature doesn't radically
change when you turn 18. so if we're
going to accept it we're just going to
accept it for everybody
now the people don't like this the
elites love this stuff the elites are
all about redefining
human nature and family and politics
there are all sorts of political and
economic reasons for this maybe we'll
get into some of those the further we
get into pride month that'll be my
little teaser for the rest of the month
but
the people don't really like this and
that's why Target lost what
how many 10 billion dollars in market
cap I think yeah Target loses 10 bill in
market cap transheiser Bush loses 12 and
a half bill in market cap what's going
to happen to Kohl's
I don't know yet this news just broke I
certainly hope people boycott coals
I certainly hope people Force the CEO of
Kohl's to resign I certainly hope that
Kohl's loses a ton of money in market
capitalization we need to put these
people out of business the radical
Elites who are pushing
deeply wrong false unpopular
views of society and human nature and
politics we've got to put those people
out of business
we need to replace the current rulers of
society in our political class in our
financial class in our cultural class
and the media we have to replace those
rulers it's not that we're going to lead
a revolution and break up the whole
system and our entire Society is going
to turn to rebel and we're going to
rebuild it from nothing we're not going
to do that we shouldn't do that but
we've very much need to replace who the
rulers are right now
Personnel is policy and all sorts of
theorizing abstracting revolutionary
types they always want to remake the
whole system well one very practical way
to do that is just to point out the
people at the top the people who are
running the show companies like Kohl's
and transheiser Bush and Target these
are people who have bought into this
agenda and they've been promoted and
they've been credentialed and they've
been put in their positions in no small
part because they bought into that
agenda we need we need to make sure that
they get fired and they don't get to
work again in any positions of authority
so that we can replace them with people
who have common sense and recognize the
truth and then they can start to slowly
turn the ship of state and the ship of
Commerce and the ship of society away
from this madness now one way that we
are training people to do that is with
Prager you right now go to prageru.com
Club five our country might be headed in
the wrong direction but prageru videos
could help save the future of America
prageru makes educational pro-american
content that has been changing people's
minds for over a decade their impact is
pivotal in these times our friends of
Prager you are reaching millions of
people with their educational videos but
they've got a long way to go you can
help prageru reach thousands more people
by joining Club five that's the number
five for just five bucks or more per
month go to prageru.com Club five now to
join your gift will ensure that prageru
has the support it needs to be here for
the long haul you know I host a show at
prageru which is called the book club
new episodes at every month and I've
also been the host of many of the five
minute videos that's what you will be
supporting at Club five so what are you
waiting for join a movement with
thousands of fellow Patriots in the
fight to save America you will receive a
free Prager u-bumper sticker plus an
e-book of scripts from prageru's five
minute videos when you join Club five
today that is prageru.com Club five
today right now go to geniusell.com
have upgraded their most popular package
to feature their top selling deep
firming vitamin C serum plus Ultra
retinol moisturizer with natural retinol
alternative right now you can take
advantage of this limited time package
upgrade for seventy seven zero percent
off why waste time and money to go get
work done to your face when you can get
genucel skin care shipped right to your
door here's a geniusell.com review from
Robert in blessing Texas quote I
purchased geniusell as a gift for my
girlfriend she said she saw the results
so fast her skin is noticeably softer
and smoother I can see and feel a
difference too she was already beautiful
and geniuselle has made her more
beautiful you might think that geniusell
is just for ladies actually frankly
probably slightly more men even than
women get it it's just wonderful help
you look better geniusell's secret is a
family recipe for over 20 years makes it
safe for all skin types and perfect for
both men and women also the founder of
geniusell is this great Coptic Christian
from Egypt who fled Egypt for the
American dream so right now head on over
to geniusell.com Knowles try Jenny cells
popular package for seventy seven zero
percent off featuring both geniusell's
Ultra retinol and Geniuses Firming Serum
get a complimentary Spa Essentials box
with every package order plus free
upgrade to priority shipping
geniusell.com Knowles
you think that Target just accidentally
started selling all this weird Pride kid
stuff oh Whoopsie Daisy it was probably
just a rogue VP of marketing like
happened at transheiser Bush remember
the marketing executive Alyssa
hershenfeld or something she was the
Rogue person at Bud Light That sponsored
Dylan Mulvaney and the senior Executives
they had no idea and I told you from the
beginning I said that is a BS line
they're trying to make this girl take
the fall because she had some videos
that were unflattering of her where she
was mocking the Bud Light customer base
and so she was an easy fall man for it
but I said this went way higher than the
VP of marketing Alyssa whatever her name
is this goes all the way to the top Bud
Light for years has embraced the rainbow
flag Bud Light is is part of all sorts
of international
multi-corporation entities that promote
this ideology in fact Bud Light requires
on having a high score from the Human
Rights Campaign which is the
euphemistically preposterously named
pro-lgbt group to give them a special
score that will then relate to their ESG
score which is one of the Criterion by
which the asset managers the big
institutional investors determine who
gets money and power and influence in
society so this goes back way further
and it goes way higher than any VP of
marketing
same thing straight Target Target has
repeatedly donated
to a group that secretly transes the
kids this is the gay lesbian straight
education Network
known as GL Sen
it's an entity which helps teachers
Place lgbtq Books in school libraries
and hides their students so-called
gender transitions from parents
this goes a lot deeper than anybody
thought and so if we're going to replace
the current Elite we can't accept the
The Limited hangout that these
corporations and political entities are
giving us where they say okay here's
some random middle manager VP of
marketing yeah okay she's fired or she's
placed on administrative leave but we're
going to leave the rest of the
executives in charge no we have to
replace the current Elite personnel is
policy boy what a great clip that was
make sure you ring the bell and
subscribe to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel we'll see you next time